let's take crypto
agrp one stream to another love remains
same prashant says
understood you can go soon to her to the
hairdresser again ah
yeah okay
knight c3 knight c6
interesting combines the g3 system with
knight on f3 that's not supposed to be
um not supposed to be very common
let's do this move i'm not sure it's a
good move
giving a bishop pair but it's what uh
that's what i can do and makes my play
very easy also i think knightly always a
bit misplaced in these uh
situations because
the d4 square then becomes available for
my knight
yeah i think i'm happy to take the dark
square bishop
oh he just provoked weakness okay that
was clever
flip yeah but guys flip is not for me
yeah it's for the
how it's called the moderator or no yeah
the one who runs
the one who runs this stream
she has to flip she already flipped she
says
she already flipped so all good guys all
good don't spread rumors
flipping against the crypto is what we
are doing now
2095 guys is a rating i should be able
to handle but so far he's playing very
well i have to give it to him he's
playing very fine
i regret my decision of giving up the
bishop
you should remove the knight from c3 to
d1 and then push c3
hopefully both you want to eat this game
that's a good one
i'm a banana look my profile much more
chiller is uh
banana creates antimatter is that a
cheat
yeah this is not a cheat
if cheating would be limited
to people consuming banana
then to not be a problem
yeah i'm really not playing it well i
have to say he got rid of his bad knight
he has bishop pair
everything is fine in his position
uh he's playing well and confidently at
the same time
my own speech is intimidating me i'm
getting intimidated by my own speech
i'll just lock him up
i'll lock him up and i'll try to
to win the long long battle
i don't know i want to i don't if i
let's try to run let's for fun let's for
fun run
let's run we can do a fun thing we can
lock everything and flag him
that's kind of a
kind of a fun little thing but i'm not
going to lock the queen side
i do want to but i'm not going to
um he wants to bring the queen to g3 and
then take on f5
i don't know
yeah i was waiting until he figures that
out
bishop belongs on h4 i don't know what
it is guys but
the last um few blitz games that i've
played they've been all so bad
i played some blizz games yesterday
jesus they were so bad
even for my standards
i won most of them obviously but still
yeah it's really bad what i'm doing but
okay f5 is crushing
i'm gonna bluff it a little bit
i have to bluffs a little bit guys
wait nightbot are you promoting somebody
else's chestable course during my
streaming time
how dare you it's nightbot because i'm
produced so many checkable courses
and what you are doing is promoting some
other ones this is so uncool
this is so uncool
but it's fine it's fine it's fine guys
go get that uh quiz gambit
declined adjustable course while there
is a huge game that accepted choseable
course out there by my own wife
that's fine nightbot can promote all
what you want
it's up to you i'm getting so crushed
i'm getting so crushed it's really
embarrassing because the guy is clearly
just out playing me
and not only that he has outplaying me
that he lets me go that he outplays me
again
that is because i play so bad
rook f6 jesus
draw no i don't want draw i don't want
draw
you are 2095
you are not capable of
beating me
you are uncapable of beating me my
friend
okay there we go there we go there we go
mistake mistake mistake mistake
but now things have changed
haven't they
queen e8 was a bit more accurate i guess
now rook of seven is there
but it doesn't okay okay now yeah now we
got him
now we got him see guys sometimes you
gotta refuse to draw
if you are one thousand uh iterated
points
you already points 1000 points of
irration higher
you should refuse the draw
as a rule as a rule
okay it's kind of
uh it's kind of not easy this position
but
i think there should be enough
resources to flag him without feeling
ashamed
of that
push before maybe i can even oh bishop
a4 i missed that oh no fba
i have to i think i'm okay i think i can
get away with my blunder
i can get away with my bladder
it's okay my only weakness would be
defended by the king i should have put
the bishop here on a3
what a tough game guys
what a tough game
this crypto for you
is crypto for you
we trade our bishops maybe
you have to eat more bananas somebody
says
okay if you don't mind then i will i was
just thinking i'll kind of be nice you
know not eat on
on stream i'm not like hikaru who
streams all day long and has no time to
eat
but today i am today i am a little bit
of a hikaru
i'm not going to rush it i'm just going
to you know
slow dance it
i'm going to do it nicely slow
i don't know what i'm doing
hmm
let's go to the queen side actually
difficult to win this position guys
actually maybe i can
send the knight somewhere
do we have increment oh we have
increment oh
jesus i'm trying to flag him my god what
am i doing
what am i doing i'm trying to flag him
when he has increment
i'm thinking why does the game last so
long i should should have flagged him
long time ago by now
okay okay let's focus them
h5 i think i can do h5
jesus yeah guys i'm really sorry
oh i should i would have played
differently also i was just thinking i'm
in the flag villa you know
in the flagler my favorite town
i was thinking we were chilling here in
the flag wheel but then uh suddenly
the truth dawned on me
he's so good
so incredibly tight this guy jesus
oh my it's not winning is it
i don't know how to do it i honestly
don't know how to do it
wait knight to b2
and knight to a4 at some point i was
there
yeah i'll i'll get him i'll get him yeah
knight c to yeah i'll get him i'll get
him
i got him chad i got him i got him chad
i got him chad
there's a lesson for you guys always uh
always be aware of the time control
geez finally i got him
wasn't easy
i'll just send my pawns down the board
and see what happens
this is why magnus accepts only without
increment
and then says oh yeah i was too slow
yeah no no no guys we are we're good
we're good we are there um